[موسيقى]
السعوديه تصعد الارجنتين في مباراه
تاريخيه بكاس العالم كشف تفاصيل جديده حول
ظهور ابنه زعيم كوريا الشماليه الان ماسك
يخسر 100 مليار دولار الى العام 2022 هذه
الاخبار وغيرها انقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
نبدا من الخبر الاكثر تداولا في السوشل
ميديا حيث حققها المنتخب السعودي
وسالم الدوسري بقلبي موازين اللقاء في
الدقائق الاولى من الشوط الثاني ليحصد
الاخضر بهذا الفوز ثلاث نقاط ثمينه ويتصدر
مجموعته في انتظار النتيجه منتخب بولندا
وبعد الفوز التاريخي للمنتخب السعودي على
ميسي ورفاقه عمت فرحه واسعه الجماهير
العربيه والسعوديه داخل مدرجات ملعب لوسيل
وخارجها وسط شهادات كبيره باداء اللاعب
الاخضر
مصوره متداوله في السوشيال ميديا اظهرت
ايضا حضور امير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد في
مدرجات الوسيله متوشحا بعالم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
لكره القدم فوز المنتخب السعودي بانه احدى
اكبر المفاجات في تاريخ كاس العالم
بعد ما اثار ظهورها رفقه والدها ضجه واسعه
في مواقع التواصل اوضح جهاز الاستخبارات
الوطنيه في كوريا الجنوبيه ان ابنه الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون هي طفلته
الثانيه وفي جلسه مغلقه امام لجنه
برلمانيه في سوق قال مسؤول الاستخبارات ان
هذه هي الابنه الثانيه لكم وتدعى جو ايه
دون ذكر المزيد من التفاصيل عنها في ما
كانت كوريا الشماليه اعلنت السبطه الماضيه
ان كنت تابع عمليه اطلاق اقوى صاروخ
باليستيك عابر للقارات برفقه زوجته ريسول
جوا وابنتهما الحبيبه على حد وصف البيان
الرسمي
فلسطين هذه المره حيث قال علماء ان هناك
تفسيرا محتملا لظاهره تجول مئات الاغنام
بشكل دائري منذ 12 يوم على التوالي في
منطقه منغوليا ادخليا علماء بجامعه
بريطانيا او بالجامعه بريطانيا اوضح ان
الاغنام قد تكون بقيه داخل الحظيره لفترات
طويله وهذا قد يؤدي الى سلوك النمطي مع
الدوران المتكرر بسبب الاحباط من التواجد
في مساحه محدوده مشيرين الى انضمام اغنام
اخرى الى المسيره الدائريه يعود لانها
حيوانات قطيعيه تقوم بما تقوم به الاغنام
الاخرى
وفي خبرنا الاخير افادت وكاله بلومبيرغ
بان رجل الاعمال الامريكي الالماس خسر
اكثر من 100 مليار دولار في عام 2022
الوكاله اوضحت ان ثروه ماسك انخفضت بمستوى
اكثر من غيره من الشخصيات المدرجه على
مؤشر الملياردات مشيره الى ان ماسك ورغم
تراجع ثروته فانه ماذا اغنى شخص في العالم
اذ يمتلك نحو 170 مليار دولار فيما كان
مالك تويتر الجديد خسر في يوم الاثنين
تحديدا نحو 9 مليارات دولار في ظل انخفاض
اسهم شركه اصلاح
[موسيقى]